يودع الحجاج العراقيون ذويهم قبل التوجه
الى السعوديه والاراضي المقدسه عبر طريق
الحج البري الممتد من صحراء النخيب الى
منفذ جديده عرعر للشعب العراقي
الازدهار والصحه والسلامه
ونشكرهم على خدمه الحجاج والزائرين والله
اتمنى الامن والامان ان شاء الله يعم على
جميع امه محمد
وشافي كل مريض
ان شاء الله يزيح الغمه هذه السوداء عنا
مثل ما يقولوا خلينا بامن وامان ان شاء
الله بجاه نبينا محمد
اكثر من خمسه عشر الف حاج قادمون من
محافظات الديوانيه والسماوه وكركوك
بالاضافه الى قوافل اقليم كردستان التي
ستمر لاول مره من هنا فالمسؤولون اكدوا ان
اجراءات التفويج ستكون مبسطه وسريعه
وتوفر معها كافه الخدمات للحجاج هناك
اهتمام وتوجيهات
باستقبال الحجاج وتهيئه كل مستلزمات
الراحه وتيسير الامور اليهم هناك محطه هنا
في كربلاء المقدسه في مركز المدينه للحجاج
وهناك محطه اخرى في مركز المشكاه بين محطه
كربلاء المقدسه ومحافظه الانبار من اجل
تقديم الخدمات الى الحجاج الاكارم وهناك
طبعا قوات امنيه تصاحبهم الى منفذ عرعر
الحدودي مباشره قياده عمليات كربلاء
المقدسه والقطاعتهم بها بتنفيذ الخط
الخاصه بتفويج ضيوف الرحمن هذه اليوم احنا
اليوم الثالث على التوالي قوافل جميع
المحافظ العراق في اتجاه المقدسه من
كربلاء فاتجاه النخيب وباتجاه عرعر تسعون
كيلو مترا هو طول الطريق بين العراق وحدود
المملكه العربيه السعوديه حيث تعمل القوات
الامنيه على تامينه ليله نهار فالحكومه
العراقيه تعتبر شريانا حيويا لاختزاله
الوقت والكلفه الماديه لحجاج بيت الله
الحرام من كربلاء شاكر عواد العربيه
[موسيقى]
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات